The Joe Rogan Experience you know coming
back to food food intelligence
uh China right now is hoarding grain
they they Supply 60 of the world's grain
they've been hoarding it for a while
actually maybe a year and a half two
years so we're gonna have a shortage uh
a global shortage the the meat
processors they're not interested in
really using livestock anymore it's just
a lot more profitable
and we're training people you know oh
now it's an amazing thing and you know
um uh is it Burger King or um someone
just came out with you know new soy
McNugget nuggets
um you know we're being kind of pushed
into this and all we know is we put it
in our face it has the same texture it
tastes the right way
and um and the profits are much better
so that's where people are starting to
reach out and say well you know why
don't I go go meet a Rancher one day and
you know and uh and a local processor
it's not USDA they can't get that but in
Texas you're allowed to sell you know
your meat directly uh without USDA stamp
one of the few States
um vegetables all this stuff we're gonna
have to figure it out because we're
gonna have shortages I think we're gonna
have some serious food shortages it'll
be weird like bread might not show up or
something else will happen but we're
gonna have shortages well we have a
bunch of problems right one of the big
ones is large population centers aren't
self-sustainable entirely not no yeah
they need food shipped into them which
is really foods and he really weird if
you think about the size of like a New
York City it's enormous right there's so
many people there's a building it's a
perfect place because the buildings are
stacked on top of each other and
everything is like like when you're
there you're like wow that's so much
pretty much so much [ __ ] energy in
this place yeah but like nothing's I
mean very little is getting grown in
terms of food
very little nothing definitely not
enough to sustain it no so you got to
keep shipping things in so you got to
keep the roads good because you're
always just bringing things in on boats
and bringing things in on trucks
everything has to come in I mean uh when
you the one of the cool things about
like watching a video about a really
good restaurant is seeing them going to
meet the fish as the fish are coming in
off the boats yeah everything has to get
there yeah someone's got to deliver
something they gotta go to Farmers
Market and get these big crates from
someone way the [ __ ] away who grew well
we used to have a fish market uh you
know which became very popular to live
uh you know in uh in New York it
literally was the the fish market and
the [ __ ] came in the guys were slicing
[ __ ] up and moving it out in the middle
of the night it was a dangerous place to
be lots of hookers in that neighborhood
it was cool as [ __ ] and now it's like
you know three million dollar uh one uh
one bedroom apartments there those are
hard men that fillet fish all day oh
yeah those are hard [ __ ] men yeah
it's very hard that is a hard job that's
a real [ __ ] job and you're seeing
that too you know kids are looking
around and their parents are saying you
know maybe not go to college maybe go to
Vocational School learn learn to trade
there's plenty of be entrepreneurial
yeah seeing a lot of that so you're uh
you're an optimist always always that's
good because there's a lot of people
that share your perspective that that
there's some serious [ __ ] things that
are wrong I wanted to talk to them about
like the grain thing first of all I did
not I've never heard the China grain
thing I only learned it recently myself
yeah it's uh it says according to data
from the U.S department of Agriculture
China is expected to have 69 of the
globe's Maize reserves I like how they
use the Native American terms so it's
like Cinema it's maze it's not corn it's
so open-minded uh in the first half of
crop year 2022 60 of its rice and 51 of
its wheat yeah here's my thing you can
keep all that [ __ ] because it's not good
for you anyway how about that well this
is another thing can we stop with the
rapeseed oil and canola oil already that
shit's not good for you right that is
industrial sludge brother and everyone's
cooking with it it's in everything yeah
the market because it's rapeseed oil but
now we call it canola oil the marketing
has been fantastic is a rough word to
sell it's a health conscious folk have
you had any rape seeds well I feel like
it when I've had it yeah it's
um there's a a well-known fact that
um there's too much much grain in a lot
of people's diets yeah in terms of like
people that eat bread all day and pasta
and like come on like that's not
something you should have all day like
do you use animals for cooking what do
you use for cooking yeah beef Tallow
okay because most people there was a I
think a psyop basically on the American
people it's like oh that's going to kill
you you can't have uh you can't use a
protein beef protein for your fat for
cooking
because they wanted
we'll just have to explain people are
asked money I use avocado money
sometimes yeah it's got us hi the answer
is money it's always money yeah I mean
look it's great stuff rapes you know and
more and more farmers are being
incentivized in the United States to
grow the last Harvest what is it what
exactly does those processed seed oils
do that's bad to you because there's a
lot of people that are like hardcore on
it like Paul saladino is very hardcore
on it Rob Wolf's very hardcore on it I
believe I hope I'm not misrepresenting
his position but I think a lot of those
guys think you should avoid those kind
of fats like those kind of those
processed seed oils well here's what I
know the process is number one right
I've learned this from my buddy Texas
Slim that's a great name yes well and he
kind of came out of semi-retirement he's
a little bit young he's about our age a
little younger
um to start the beef initiative and so
he's setting it up so people are getting
connected with you know just basically
with directly with farmers and food and
you know using Bitcoin is kind of the
common network but more importantly he's
writing and educating people
um uh about food and one of the most
compelling Arguments for me he said look
at pictures of my because he's a 12th
generation Texan or something so look at
pictures of my great great grandparents
how do they look you know they they got
some shitty ass clothes on but they look
pretty good yeah now now go to Houston
how do people look now so what's the
difference the people who used to live
off of beef in Texas
um you know it's not a great place to to
grow you know Seas but we have the
original seeds the ones that aren't you
know genetically modified
the the the beat you know the the cattle
manure that that fertilize the ground
not using artificial stuff you know you
know whatever you need to to hyper grow
stuff and we look much better and now go
to Houston everyone's obese so you know
it's got to be at the intake it's got to
be at the input it's not just the
sedentary well I think there's a lot of
people around here people are very
active a lot of people exercise a lot of
young but people aren't that healthy
looking even in Austin it's not all that
great no no I don't think so